bonjour katia les débats risque à
nouveau d'être houleux oui en effet
certains amendements font tous font
toujours polémique et pourtant le sénat
avait expurgé le texte de nombreux
éléments il s'était prononcé en faveur
de la pma pour tout un mais en tout cas
ces éléments qui faisait polémique pour
le sénat sont revenus dans le texte
après l'examen de la commission spéciale
alors lesquels sont ils par exemple la
reconnaissance de l'enfant pour le deux
parents du couple homosexuel et y
compris pour celui qui n'est pas le
parent génétique au lieu de l'adoption
et puis le remboursement de la pma pour
toutes au titre des amendements examinés
par exemple la congélation ovocytaire la
recherche sur l'embryon de ça c'est
encore un thème polémique ou encore
l'hybridation de cellules animales et
humaines au sein de la recherche et même
le diagnostic préimplantatoire alors ça
par exemple
cela permet aux femmes qui ont recours à
une pma de déterminer si l'embryon a
implanté un patrimoine génétique
comportant des anomalies ou non et bien
certains en sont opposés au diagnostic
préimplantatoire quand vous voyez la
polémique se niche partout opposants au
projet qui se sont déjà manifestés tout
à l'heure
alors en effet car des représentants
dirons-nous des associations de la
famille traditionnelle pour faveur de la
famille traditionnelle se sont regroupés
à proximité de l'assemblée nationale
mais ils n'étaient que 25 peux pas dire
ce soir un rassemblement extrêmement
fourni en revanche les parlementaires de
l'opposition fait connaître déjà leur
colère vis-à-vis d'une part du
calendrier parce que le cet examen est
prévu à la fin du mois de juillet la
estime que cet examen est fait en
catimini à une période où ce n'était pas
forcément une priorité
et puis il conteste aussi le fait que
les portelais départ dont les
parlementaires n'ont que 25 heures pour
examiner c'est plus de 2000 un moment à
deux mille amendements
merci beaucoup katia technique depuis le
palais bourbon